I don't encourage people to say please
pretty please song
okay I'm thank you good luck John says
thanks for the game I hope the 84 points
was a worth our friendship it was very
much worth it thanks John
oh then I'll play wizard Danny next
really incentivizing on begging behavior
but anyway um let's move on let's also
turn on the sound sound sound sound
speech synthesis ribbon d4 I've not
considered shaving my hair just yet oh
wait no I still look slightly more blind
wait what does Neil play doesn't you
play London okay thinking
d for let's play d5 wait why is this tie
not click it
let's try that I can do 45 okay let's go
we shall begin was that Neal or was that
the wizard Danny was not moving 2
minutes 44 seconds he was getting
distracted black 3 minutes 30 seconds
wait did I challenge this wait 3 minutes
30 seconds wait
c4 okay I'll play so I play I'll play e5
c5 document 2 minutes 36 seconds black 3
minutes 21 seconds oh maybe I just meant
you take sine Phi D takes e5 is 15 more
okay so I have an album counter gambit 9
f3 Knight f3 I'll play Knight to c6 96
b3 b3 not b3 b3 I guess p3 is a playable
move think about f6 here 6 is kind of 6
all previous - it is 3/3 hehehehe
it's 3 3 3 minutes 30 seconds Knight
takes f6 they should have b2 maybe I
misheard should be too they should have
b2 should be 2 let's play um there's a V
fortune they should have before check
maybe Queenie southern come tonight BD -
Queen d7 a3 b3
let's play maybe I should see five they
should have see five
hmmm interesting position before 95 wait
no not gonna be 5 no you take c5 yes
Oh d3 checkmate Oh black is victorious
good game you those nice yeah maybe I'll
put that game on you too
thanks for the game
III pre-move 95 expecting before I had
to try and play it off as a slip it's
such a nice to meet - I guess smothered
means doesn't happen so often hey it's
Sonja lang
Sonja Lang I got your book the book by
Sonja leg also YouTube people watching
in the future thanks for watching
Neal good game thanks her things for all
the gifted subs and the delicious
smothered me